[Music]
foreign you're watching the Press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages as they arrive it's time to
see what's making headlines with the
associate editor of the Daily Mirror
Kevin McGuire and the deputy comment
editor at the telegraph Annabelle denim
they'll be with us from now until just
before midnight let's see what is on
some of those front pages and we'll
start with the front page of the Metro
which leads with the visual held for the
two students killed in Nottingham
thousands turned up to support The
Grieving families of Grace so malikuma
and Barnaby Weber
a similar headline for the Daily Express
which describes the mood of the vigil as
one of numb and comprehending grief
The Daily Mail focuses on the emotional
speeches made by both the victim's
fathers
the times picks add a quote from Grace's
father where he encouraged mourners to
look after each other and love everyone
the guardian reports on a groundbreaking
scientific Advance where scientists have
sidestepped the need for eggs and sperm
by creating a synthetic embryo using
stem cells
The Daily Telegraph reports on Boris
Johnson calling for sir Bernard Jenkin
to be removed from the Privileges
committee over his alleged lockdown rule
breaking
that's an image from Silvio berlusconi's
funeral on the front of the financial
times which also says there's pressure
on the Prime Minister over increasing
mortgage rates
and mortgages on the front of the I2
which says the tour is risk losing the
support of homeowners
and there's an AI warning from Elon Musk
on the front of the Daily Star
and a reminder by scanning the QR codes
you see on screen during the program you
can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's papers while you watch along
with us all right well tonight we're
joined by Kevin McGuire and Annabelle
denim there they are in the big screen
good evening to you both Kevin Annabelle
great to have you with us and we'll
start with the front page of the Metro
Kevin
um and then as we said a number of
papers tomorrow covering that vigil in
Nottingham and these families grief
um there for everyone to see
no no absolutely incredibly moving
scenes the matter have gone for the
headline United in love that's the the
love of uh you know their children to
grieving families and the father spoke
uh so movingly as did others and it's
almost impossible the only people who
will really know how they feel are those
who've suffered something similar uh
because it's beyond the comprehension of
most of us to to lose a child in such a
violent uh uh horrific way but it's uh
how do those families cope uh how does
the students friends family uh you know
and also the those the friends and
family of uh have been 65 the school
caretaker who was uh was also murdered
in his van taken how do they cope and
that's that's the big question but uh
you know people are incredibly resilient
but listening to the father's uh you
know speak uh you know Barnaby's say he
doesn't know how it happened doesn't
know how you'll deal with it and Grace's
dad uh pictured there uh say look look
after each other it's uh it's just kind
of it's kind of really shocking that it
that it happened but it's now how do we
use as people respond and deal with it
yeah uh let's look at the front of the
of the mail if we can now
um Annabelle uh as we talk about those
two fathers who
just showed Incredible strength to be
able to talk just a day after losing
their their children uh as Kevin said it
was it was so emotional so touching um
and really painful to kind of hear the
raw emotion that these guys are going
through
absolutely you know it's just it's just
awful and
I thought so with those grief stricken
families like Kevin says it's simply
Beyond every parent's worst nightmare
it's it's impossible to imagine and I
think that this trauma will be felt so
widely thousands of students attending
that vigil and like you say I think so
staggered really at the courage and
composure of those two fathers so soon
after this very violent uh attack and I
think you know I was really struck by
how this was happening to kids at
University this is often the first time
that people are away from their families
and indeed were the first time that
parents are sending their children away
and you know this this is simply the
absolute last thing that you would
expect to have happen and now you know
as time passes I think people are going
to want explanations they're going to
want answers we cannot understand we
cannot fathom why this happened we're
only beginning to learn in details about
the murder suspect and you know I think
we simply want to know what it was that
led to this absolutely heinous act uh
and Kevin do you think there are going
to be those questions to be asked about
um the person who's responsible of
course there is someone in custody at
the moment a restaurant suspicion of
murder
um
to try and find out exactly what's
transpired the men that a person like
this
um was able to carry out this kind of
act
yeah there has to be person in in
custody the police say they're not
looking for anybody else uh and you've
got to understand we've got to
understand why why whoever did this I
know there's a legal process here why
who did this did it and you know where
their opportunities to stop them doing
it that was somehow missed uh I'm I
don't intend to you know or mean to
blame anybody on that but you know maybe
maybe lessons can be learned because it
is just uh absolutely appalling to how
somebody could murder three people two
students a mountain 65 still working uh
he uses van to run over three other
people one of uh whom is critically
injured is just it's just terrible it is
it is beyond beyond the comprehension of
most of us we have to get our heads
around it understand why why it happened
and how it might as it might have been
uh prevented all those questions have to
be asked yeah they do perhaps lessons to
be learned
the number of families Shattered by what
happened in Nottingham yesterday all
right let's move on to some of the
politics that are on the front pages now
and animal let's start off with you the
front page of the eye here um there's
the headline Tori is losing support from
home owners as hunt backs new rate hike
talk us through the reporting here
sure
homeowners are turning away from the
conservatives I don't think this is all
together it's surprising let's not
forget the one where she's Scenic came
into number 10 the impression that he
gave was one of a quiet competence that
he and Jeremy Hunt would be very safe
fans on the tiller and now it looks very
much like they have lost control of the
economy what we are seeing uh is Banks
um freezing off some of their offers
um perhaps raising mortgage rates in
response to the expectation that there
will be interest rates increases and why
we get why are those expectations
changing well it's off the back of this
very sticky inflation that we've seen
despite rishi's soon act pledging that
inflation would be halved by the end of
the year it is remaining stubbornly high
and earlier this week we had ons labor
market data that found that wage growth
has gone up by seven percent now this is
still
um a reduction in real terms but is
nonetheless and absolutely massive
number and it renews fears that we now
find ourselves in some kind of wage
price spiral where prices on the shelves
are going up so people are then going to
be demanding pay rate pay raises in
order to fund it which in turn is going
to lead to companies needing to increase
their prices uh in order to meet those
paid demands and you can see how you get
into that spiral which Jeremy Hunt which
Rishi sunak which Andrew Bailey are all
absolutely terrified of and you know as
the eye is pointing out this is simply
something that the Tories cannot ignore
they are going to pay for this at the
next general election unless they can
find a way to uh grow the economy to cut
taxes
um you know and to to bring down
inflation it's not exactly within Jeremy
Hunt and where she's saying that's gift
it's very much the responsibility of the
monetary policy committee at the bank of
England but nonetheless it looks like
um the most senior members of our
government are throwing their weight
behind the decisions that the MPC will
be making yeah and I'm glad you
mentioned that wage price spiral Kevin
because that is what has always been
Finn what's been talked about but Kevin
as you know and I saw you shaking ahead
of some of that there is another way of
doing this and if you look at what's
happened in the states right now they've
paused the rate Rises they've managed to
get inflation under control so there are
other factors and the comparisons don't
often work I mean
Annabelle said you know that was a
promise by Rishi sunat to bring
inflation down its remaining sticky it's
maybe going up and rates are rising as
well
so uh next week uh expected to go up
again with uh Jeremy Hunt back in it and
the the Ft uh rather similarly to to the
eye I pointed out sunak's gonna feel the
hit on this because they are rapid
mortgage risers dominating prime
minister's questions uh uh Kia storm are
basically saying you know sunak's being
distracted all this nonsense with uh
Johnson and honors but the hsbc's put up
uh cost of borrowing twice a week it's
worth remembering that in December 2021
as recently as then it interesting is
from 0.1 percent the base rate is now
4.5 and it's going to go higher that's
an extra extraordinary rise and it's
quite right that inflation eats into the
value of you your wages wages are
chasing inflation inflation is not too
wages aren't creating the inflation it's
wages are chasing inflation but it
damages your living standards High
inflation but so do your mortgage
interest rates as they take you take
your spending power away so it's it's
kind of people are under under assault
uh from two directions when you've got
inflation of what you buy is going up in
price and then your your mortgages your
car loans your credit cards they're
going up too another you're kind of
touching it a little bit in your answer
there there's all the criticism coming
from some of the conservative Parts
towards the um Bank of England monetary
policy committee but I mean my thought
on this is as rates keep going up and
we're going to start seeing other parts
of the political divide perhaps
questioning the way that the bank of
England have been raising rates there
was a question that perhaps they should
have got a hold of this earlier and
didn't act quickly enough and those
criticisms sort of are lingering aren't
they now
yes in fact I think the government was
quite slow to criticize that Bank of
England for having extremely loose
monetary policy for far too long and you
know the bank of England has had a bit
of a Communications disaster ever since
it allowed this massive increase in the
water power of money during the
coronavirus uh pandemic Andrew Bailey
has been very quick to blame workers or
particularly older workers who've
decided to retire and he's criticized
those who've asked for pay Rises which I
think is frankly immoral people should
go to their employer and try and get the
best pay that they possibly can he
criticized some companies for their
pricing structures and I think it's
really time that the bank of England
took responsibility it was during in a
very difficult position during the
pandemic it was under immense pressure
to print money so that the government
could fund support packages such as the
70 billion pound furlough scheme but
that doesn't explain why it was so slow
to wake up to the inflationary threat
and to suggest for a really long time
that it was transitory I think we all
know now uh who we are in June 2023 that
inflation is not transitory it's very
damaging for the bank of England what it
needs more than anything else is to
restore credibility only then well
expectations of interest rates Rises
come down once people have realized um
or at least expect that the bank of
England will get conflation under
control uh but until that point you know
we are going to see Banks to making
these sorts of moves increasing uh
mortgage rates perhaps pulling deals off
uh the market and for Richie sooner like
the front of the financial times says
this is extremely awkward let's not
forget that it was fears about a
mortgage time bomb that contributed to
the ousting of Liz truss and now the
cost of government borrowing is higher
than it was after truss's mini budget so
the question will be does Rishi sooner
face similar risks I think it's unlikely
but undoubtedly he is in a very
uncomfortable position indeed and a
quick thought from you on where the
labor player will position themselves on
this that I haven't yet heard sort of
criticism of the bank of England coming
from uh people in the on the in the
shadow treasury in the labor party but
where will they position themselves
considering the fact that you know in 18
months time they actually could be in
power
yeah politically it suits labor to
attack uh the UK conservative government
uh Russia sunak the Prime Minister
Jeremy Hunt uh the the chancellor as as
well as uh as Liz trust but they want to
they want a penny on the current
politicians that's why they think
they're not having it having a go at the
bank of England there's no doubt the
bank of England has been slow there's a
big Splurge of uh inflation after Energy
prices went through the roof uh as did
uh food prices after the Putin invasion
of Ukraine you can't blame the UK
conservative government for that but you
can come in complain and or critique its
handling of a crisis but no it suits it
suits labor to go for the politicians
rather than the bank Annabelle desperate
Johnson hits out at Tori MPS laid into
sir Bernard Jenkin why
yes uh so he is calling for uh the Brett
support the brexit supporting uh
conservative Bradley sir Bernard Jenkin
to uh resign this is following
um him allegedly attending an event to
mark his wife's 65th birthday at which
there were drinks and yes cake in
December 2022 when indoor socializing
was banned in London uh it's about a
Jenkins to died attending a drinks party
an ally has said that no rules were
broken this feels like Boris Johnson is
slightly clutching at straws I'm not
sure that there's been that much
widespread Sympathy for the idea that
this was a kangaroo court uh even if it
did at times feel as though it was
rigged against him the fundamental fact
uh remains that Boris Johnson has
resigned with immediate effect very few
sanctions will be able to be imposed on
him uh once the Privileges committee
report has been published which which is
obviously expected tomorrow I think this
just represents yet more Blue on Blue
attacks more mud slinging which has been
going on for years now it's been going
on
since the end of 2021 if not before it
became particularly bitter during the
conservative leadership contest last
summer and frankly I think the public
are tired of it and what we'll be really
telling is whether conservative MPS are
tired of it as well because there will
be a debate on Monday on whether to
accept the report's findings Downing
Street has decided not to whip the vote
um and Tory MPS are going to be free to
cast ballots against Boris Johnson after
and let's see what they decided they now
just desperate to draw a line under the
whole Saga yeah absolutely I mean Kevin
is it just blue and blue because What's
Happening Here is that Boris Johnson's
is once again attempting to undermine
the Integrity of this committee which
feels more than just mudslinging to me
yeah
yeah no no absolutely like he was
toppled as prime minister he he's
chucked his toys out the pram and
quitters an MP probably jumped before he
was pushed by this committee and he he
will he'll go he'll go to his grave uh
doing a baby Trump uh with a temper
tantrum saying uh it's uh it's all
against uh ends meet the you know the
The Blob the committee uh has got it in
for me uh which of course is nonsense
when they've just looked at the uh the
evidence there's seven of them I
understand the report was agreed
unanimously it's a Tory majority for you
take off Bernard Jenkin and it wouldn't
make any difference anyway but he well
he doesn't grasp Johnson is the
committee isn't find him in uh in
contempt of Parliament and lying and uh
recklessly and misleading the House of
Commons because he
went to a party it's because he denied
he went to a party and lied had he went
to a party and he broke the rules that's
what it's all about so the comparison
would burn a Jenkins doesn't wash anyway
despite the fact Bernard and his T9 in
anything it is because Johnson denied
and lied to MPS in the House of Commons
that's why he is in such deep trouble uh
and he still can't get it and he's been
in his head I think he's always created
uh he's his own reality his own false
reality he's he's fantasy it's but I
suppose it's what um some of trump
supporters would call alternative facts
as we'd always grasping for and the
truth just gets lost okay final thought
Annabelle to you a different story uh
not related in the slightest um silver
burners going on the front of the uh
Financial Times being laid to rest and
quite a turnout in Milan
yes that's right and it does seem that
uh he divided opinion in life and he has
divided opinion in death it seemed like
a very fitting funeral for Sylvia
Berlusconi it was attended by his lovers
and an ex-wife his girlfriend 53 years
his Junior and I rather Like the quote
from the Archbishop of Milan who said
during his homily that Silvio Berlusconi
was certainly a figure who acquired
notoriety what a diplomatic statement
that was um but you know obviously about
balisgani he was a towering presence an
Italian life for three decades one of
the most recognizable and notorious
figures on the international stage okay
Annabelle Kevin appreciate that both
thank you very much